make sure you guys hit the subscribe
button if you guys are enjoying the
content that we're throwing up and make
sure you guys hit the like button if you
enjoy the video and yeah let's begin
okay what's going on guys this is Rob
and today on our own mega beyond Omega
level series we're gonna discuss a
character that I think is often
overlooked when thinking of the most
powerful characters in the DC Universe
but he definitely deserves to get more
respect than he actually does we of
course are talking about Larfleeze the
orange lantern now Larfleeze first
appeared in green lantern number 25 in
2008 and in terms of his origin we have
very few details about his past and
really don't even know his true name as
Larfleeze is simply an alias that he
uses what we do know about him is that
he comes from a species that lives in
extremely long time and is himself
believed to be billions of years old now
Larfleeze is kidnapped and forced to
work as a slave for cruel masters who
often starve and mistreat their slaves
to weed out the weakest among them and
after laboring in horrible conditions
Larfleeze begins to hear the voices of
the possessions of the ruling class
calling out for him to own them and so
later Larfleeze would escape his captors
and form a guild of thieves who stole a
box from the planet Malta's the original
homeworld of the guardians of the
universe as they end up following a map
left by the former Guardian Crona
which led them to a temple on the planet
Okara in the vega system where they find
a power battery that contained the
orange light representing avarice or
greed on the emotional spectrum and so
with all of them wanting the power for
themselves the band of thieves ends up
turning on each other and only two of
them are left Larfleeze and another
thief named turpa that was at this time
that the guardians of the universe end
up catching up to the thieves and offer
them a deal to allow them to keep the
orange light if they remain in the vegas
system and return the box they stole
from Altis which of course house
parallax the entity of fear furthermore
the Guardians stipulated that having two
individuals in possession of the orange
light would be too much of a danger to
the rest of the universe due to
unpredictability so only one of the
thieves could receive the power of the
orange light and to that end Larfleeze
and turba battled to the death with
Larfleeze winning and taking the power
for himself and so upon gaining the
power of the orange power battery
Larfleeze adopts the code name asian
orange and becomes the only orange
lantern in the DC Universe and as
mentioned earlier the orange power ring
is powered by avarice or grief now the
orange power ring grants its wielder all
the standard powers that the other
various rings provide most notably
flight and the ability to create hard
light constructs but the orange ring has
some unique characteristics as well for
insta
Larfleeze is able to steal the essence
of anyone he kills and add them to his
army of orange light constructs these
constructs act as orange lanterns of a
sword in that they can go out and steal
the essences of others and continue to
add to the core creating exponential
expansion the orange light also has the
ability to absorb the constructs of
other lanterns and even constructs made
by the guardians of the universe the
only exception to this seems to be the
violet energy of the star sapphire ring
since it's powered by love and therefore
immune to the effects of greed and the
blue light of the blue power ring
powered by hope since avarice cannot
erode hope and in fact blue rings are
able to negate the effects of the orange
power ring in some instances and blue
lanterns are able to negate the
insatiable greed that orange ring
wielders feel when putting on the ring
but the real thing that separates
Larfleeze from the rest of the various
lanterns of the DC Universe and makes
him so powerful is that he's basically a
one-man Lantern Court while the various
other Lantern cores have many individual
lanterns tapping into the central power
battery and in fact there's over 7,000
green lanterns for example Larfleeze is
too greedy to share his power with
anyone so he's the only one that's
tapping into the orange power battery
meaning that he's able to essentially
mainline the entirety of the greed
aspect of the emotional spectrum as a
result while most lanterns can charge
their rings to a level of 100 Larfleeze
was able to charge his ring to a level
of 100 thousand which theoretically
would place him at 1,000 times more
powerful than any other Lantern at full
charge which has led to him being
described as a biological power battery
now Larfleeze has demonstrated his
immense power against a number of
extremely powerful opponents for
instance he incapacitated Atrocitus the
leader of the Red Lantern Corps with one
shot and has broken through the green
hard light constructs of Hal Jordan
considered by most to be the greatest of
all the Green Lantern's and did this
even when Hal was drawing power from
both green and blue power rings he also
defeated an entire pantheon of gods and
what we don't know much about the gods
of the House of 2 with Dan as they only
appear in one issue and basically just
served to be punching bags for Larfleeze
they're still described as deities and
as such are presumably pretty powerful
he's over powered prana a member of the
Owen race that eventually became the
guardians of the universe that's capable
of really the power
of the emotional spectrum and battle
kyle rayner to a stalemate when he was
also channeling the entirety of the
emotional spectrum which arguably puts
Larfleeze on par with the entirety of
the emotional spectrum itself Larfleeze
has also single-handedly overpower the
guardians of the universe
the group responsible for creating the
Green Lantern Corps and are nearly
omnipotent beings furthermore Larfleeze
inspired such fear and his opponents
that Jon Stewart was hesitant to face
him even with the aid of the guardians
of the universe and the white Lantern
Kyle Rayner so yeah Larfleeze is pretty
Opie and due to the fact that he's
constantly tapped into a seemingly
limitless source of orange light energy
could likely destroy a planet without
much difficulty I think beyond this
along with the fact that he has
overpowered universe level entities such
as the guardians of the universe will
allow us to easily place Larfleeze at
Biondo mega level and I think he's
really a character that needs to get
more respect when thinking about the
most powerful entities in the DC
Universe what's being said guys we're
gonna bring this video to an end if you
are new here - comments explained make
sure you guys with the sub button to
become part of the rob4 if you guys
enjoyed this video make sure you drop a
like and I will catch you all later
loose okay I want to give a shout out to
Kyle be David Joseph Ben john h aj matt
in jeff our john h lean and mean which
is an awesome name jason see Austin s
Austin a Joey M Steven Z Austin B Adam K
and Genesis 9:6 team you remember guys
you can send me messages and I'll run
off whatever your message is at the end
of the video so long there's nothing
crazy but if you want to put a message
in there send me an email Rob at Robert
Jefferson comm and if you're one of
these people who get shout outs
then I will tack it in there and yeah
they should watch you guys
[Music]
[Music]